.
Das ist der Porsche.
So, dein Wohnzimmer.
Es ist schön, Whirlpool.
Dieser Anzug hier
kostet fast 1000 Euro.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob Geld glücklicher macht.
Ich bin auf dem Weg zu Torben.
Torben ist Millionär,
aber er ist kein Rich-Kid,
sondern hat sich
das alles selbst erarbeitet.
Ich will herausfinden, ob ihnen
dieses ganze Geld verändert hat.
Und ich frage mich auch, was würde
so viel Geld mit mir machen?
Hi. - Hi.
Frank. - Torben, grüß dich.
- Torben.
Schön, dich kennen zu lernen.
Ich habe mir einen Millionär
etwas anders vorgestellt. - Okay.
Vielleicht mit einem Anzug.
Ein bisschen wie das Bild von dir,
das da hängt.
Das bist doch du, oder?
- Das war ich mal, ja.
So schön mit Schlips.
Und irgendwie förmlicher. - Okay.
Du bist so leger.
Genau, richtig, ich glaube,
das ist ein Klischee.
Dass Millionäre
immer Anzüge tragen müssen.
Das muss man, wenn man wichtige
Business-Termine hat.
Aber ansonsten bin ich so wie jetzt.
Ja, ich bin da ganz locker.
Hier ist also dein Unternehmen.
Genau, ich habe einen
etwas größeren Immobilienbestand.
Den verwalten wir von hier aus.
Reich geworden
bist du mit Immobilien.
Ja, ich würde sagen wohlhabend
oder vermögend geworden.
Du würdest gar nicht sagen,
du bist reich?
Sondern vermögend?
Genau,
Reich kann man verschieden auslegen.
Was würdest du sagen,
wann ist man reich?
Reich ist man,
wenn man maximal glücklich ist.
Unabhängig vom Kontostand.
Für die meisten Leute ist Reichtum,
wenn man viel auf dem Konto hat.
Seit wann bist du reich?
Wohlhabend?
Ich bin wohlhabend
seit meinem 27. Lebensjahr.
Das war der Zeitpunkt, wo ich
durch meine Immobilieneinnahmen
meine laufenden Kosten decken konnte.
Ab diesem Zeitpunkt
musste ich offiziell nicht mehr aktiv
für mein Geld arbeiten gehen.
Du müsstest jetzt also
gar nicht mehr hierher kommen?
Theoretisch. Aber man hat ja Ziele.
Also, noch mehr erreichen.
Und es macht mir auch sehr viel Spaß,
das, was man schon hat,
zu vergrößern.
Was steht heute noch an bei dir,
Torben?
Ich zeige dir
heute noch meine Wohnung.
Dadurch, dass ich
so viel abgenommen habe,
brauche ich einen neuen Anzug.
Was Schickes?
- Genau.
Vielleicht ziehe ich mir
auch was Schickes an, mal sehen.
So, bitteschön.
Müssen wir einmal ganz nach oben.
So.
Das ist jetzt deine Wohnung, oder?
Die gehört mir auch.
Ich ziehe mir meine Schuhe aus.
Wie du magst,
kannst du auch anlassen.
Ich bin ein Typ,
der gerne die Schuhe auszieht.
Das ist mein Schlafzimmer.
Das Möblieren übernehme immer ich
persönlich überall beleuchtet.
Komm mal mit in mein Bad.
Wasserfall.
Dann hast du hier einen Fernseher,
um in der Badewanne zu gucken.
Wie oft bist du in dieser Badewanne?
Das mag ich nicht sagen,
ist so unangenehm.
Wieso, wollte jeden Tag badest?
Seitdem ich hier wohne,
hab ich die Badewanne
noch kein einziges Mal benutzt.
Ich dusche jeden Tag hier.
Ich bade einfach nicht gerne.
Das ist mein Wohnzimmer.
Ich habe die Wohnung selbst saniert.
Die habe ich genauso gemacht,
wie ich sie gerne haben wollte.
Ich dachte, vielleicht hast du
noch eine größere, protzigere Bude.
Ich denke,
es ist schon sehr schick alles.
Es ist auch groß,
mit einer schönen Terrasse.
Hältst du dich da zurück und sagst,
ich brauche einfach nicht mehr?
Ich glaube, das täuscht.
Was hast du dir vorgestellt?
Ich dachte,
vielleicht eine ganze Etage.
Ich selber bin Single.
Für mich alleine reicht es,
ich habe zwei Zimmer.
Für mich war wichtig,
ich kann von hier aus
mein Büro gut erreichen.
Und man muss auch sagen,
finanziell erfolgreich
wird man nicht dadurch,
dass man das Geld ohne Ende raushaut.
Sondern dadurch, dass man versucht,
es beisammen zu halten.
Und das, was man spart,
auch wieder investiert.
In Dinge,
die wieder neues Geld bringen.
Zum Beispiel vermietete Immobilien.
Du würdest sagen, am Anfang
hast dir was zur Seite gelegt.
Damit was gemacht.
Mit dem Geld dann wieder was gemacht.
Man könnte sagen,
das ist mehr aus dem Sparen heraus.
Richtig, während alle anderen
ihr Geld ausgegeben haben
für Konsum, wie Urlaub,
für ein teures Auto,
während die
auf teure Konzerte gegangen sind,
teure Festivals,
da habe ich versucht,
mein Geld zusammenzuhalten,
die ersten Jahre. Das Geld zu sparen.
Und mein erstes Geld entsprechend
anzulegen in Immobilien.
Wie kam es, dass du dich
für Immobilien interessiert hast?
Dass du das Ziel hattest,
Millionär zu werden?
Ich habe früher gekellnert.
Parallel zu meiner Berufsausbildung.
Was
für eine Ausbildung hast du gemacht?
Eine als Groß- und
Außenhandelskaufmann.
Für mich war aber
vorher auch schon klar,
dass ich beruflich
immer Erfolg haben möchte.
Dass ich irgendwann
auch mal vermögend werden möchte.
Für mich war damals
aber überhaupt nicht klar,
wie ich das erreichen kann.
Beim Kellnern
habe ich jemanden kennengelernt,
das war mein damaliger Chef,
der einen eigenen
Immobilienbestand hatte,
der hatte damals rund 60 Wohnungen,
ich dachte, Wahnsinn.
Eine Art Idol? Mentor?
Ja, kann man schon sagen.
Direkt nach der Berufsausbildung
habe ich mich selbstständig gemacht.
Als Immobilienmakler.
Ich habe als Erstes
seine Wohnungen vermarktet.
Aber auch sehr viele Kunden
selber akquiriert.
Wenn ich irgendwo gehört habe,
dass jemand
ein Haus zu verkaufen hat,
eine Wohnung zu vermieten,
dann habe ich da geklingelt.
Den Eigentümer ausfindig gemacht.
Und habe über diesen Weg
den Eigentümer kennengelernt.
Und auch die Aufträge bekommen.
Hast du noch Fotos von früher?
Das ist spannend,
das ist mein aller erstes Büro.
Hier habe ich angefangen.
Das ging vom Schlafzimmer hoch.
Wir haben Teppich raufgelegt
und von dort aus gearbeitet.
Um soviel Geld zu sparen,
wie es geht.
Damit man nicht extra
noch Bürokosten hat.
Das ist sehr spannend.
Das war am Anfang
meiner Makler-Tätigkeit.
Da siehst du aus
wie ein typischer Makler.
Mit Anzug, Lackschuhen, Schlips.
Das war 2008, vor elf Jahren.
Inzwischen hat sich
das alles gewandelt.
Ich würde jetzt nicht mehr mit Anzug.
Heute nicht mehr, heute eher leger.
Es ist auch wirklich so,
die meisten wohlhabenden Leute
sind ganz normal, wie du und ich.
Wie ich das jetzt wahrnehme,
hast du nicht so viel
von zu Hause aus mitgenommen,
dass man dir unterstellen könnte,
du bist reingeboren.
Du hattest eh schon
voll die guten Voraussetzungen.
Meine Mutter ist Zahnarzthelferin.
Ich bin getrennt aufgewachsen.
Ich habe meinen Vater
alle zwei Wochen gesehen.
Mein Vater ist Schlosser gewesen.
Die haben
mit Immobilien und Vermögensaufbau
in etwa so viel am Hut,
wie ich anderen Frauen
die Nägel machen könnte.
Gar nichts.
Klingt wie die Geschichte
vom Tellerwäscher zum Millionär.
Dieses,
es kann eigentlich jeder schaffen.
Wichtig ist, man muss einfach machen.
Und dranbleiben.
Man muss mehr Einnahmen
haben als Ausgaben.
Und das, was man über hat,
in Dinge investieren, die wieder
neues Geld bringen. Fertig.
Das geht halt nicht bei Menschen,
die sich Gedanken machen müssen,
wie sie ihre nächste Miete
zahlen können.
Davon haben wir in
unserer Gesellschaft ja auch viele.
Die gerade so viel haben,
dass sie die Miete
vom nächsten Monat sicher haben.
Wenn man nicht jemanden kennenlernt,
der einem da Mut macht,
der einem etwas zeigt,
dann ist es noch schwieriger,
diesen Weg einzuschlagen.
Was würdest du sagen, wenn du
dir das Bild von 2008 anschaust,
was hat das Geld mit dir gemacht?
Ich denke, ich bin
verantwortungsbewusster geworden.
Geld ist einfach
eine Verantwortung, die man hat.
Auch ein Stück weit Macht.
Ich finde es sehr wichtig,
dass man diese Macht
auch entsprechend
verantwortlich einsetzt.
Das ist er.
Genau, das ist der Porsche.
Wir haben auch Massage-Sitze.
- Massage-Sitze?
Wenn du magst,
kann ich dir eine Massage anmachen.
Mach mal die Massage an. Weißt du,
was so ein Auto ungefähr kostet?
Ja, rund 200.000.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht deines.
Du hast es dir geleast?
Wofür brauchst du das denn konkret?
Brauchen tut man das natürlich nicht.
Aber es bringt einfach Spaß,
damit zu fahren.
Es steht im Widerspruch zu dem,
was du vorhin gesagt hast.
Man wird wohlhabend,
indem man weniger verbraucht,
als man einnimmt.
Das stimmt,
aber ich bin ja schon wohlhabend.
Das ist der Unterschied.
Das leistest du dir,
weil es Spaß macht? - Genau.
Ich habe überlegt,
was ich machen würde,
wenn ich super viel Kohle hätte.
Ich glaube, ich würde mir
nicht so eine dicke Karre kaufen.
Ich würde etwas Sinnvolles
damit machen wollen.
Was Soziales oder was auch immer.
- Genau, das möchte ich auch.
Was ein Traum ist,
den man so lange träumen,
bis man wirklich wohlhabend ist.
Und dann ändert sich
das ganz schnell.
Wenn man plötzlich sagt,
ich hab dafür voll viel gearbeitet.
Jetzt möchte ich mir
was richtig Geiles leisten.
Ob das manchmal nicht so eine
Wunschvorstellung ist von Leuten,
die nicht super reich,
aber auch nicht super arm sind,
wenn ich mal viel Geld hätte, dann
würde ich die Hälfte abgeben oder so.
Wichtig für mich
ist ein gesundes Mittelmaß.
Dass man materielle Dinge hat,
die man schön findet.
Wie zum Beispiel dieses Auto.
Womit man sich selbst belohnt, wenn
man eine gute Arbeit gemacht hat.
Seine Ziele erfüllt hat.
Und mit dem Geld
etwas Verantwortungsbewusstes macht.
Wie etwa Arbeitsplätze schaffen,
soziale Projekte unterstützen.
Frag dich, kannst du
das Leben nicht besser genießen,
wenn du wüsstest, du musst dir
über Geld keine Sorgen machen?
Ist es nicht
ein viel schöneres Gefühl.
Ich weiß, ehrlich gesagt,
nicht, ob Geld glücklicher macht.
Du sagst,
da kann man viel besser schlafen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Typ-Sache.
Ich denke, da kannst du recht haben.
Das ist sicher auch
eine Einstellungssache.
Willkommen am Hamburger Berg.
Das ist jetzt eine der Wohnungen,
die ich saniere.
Die ich auf Vordermann bringe.
Bitteschön.
So, willkommen in der Wohnung.
Wow. Mit Stuck.
Genau.
Die ist ja riesig.
Das ist ja eine sehr beliebte Gegend,
in der man wohnen will.
Absolut, das stimmt.
Was glaubst du,
würde diese Wohnung kosten?
Ungefähr 2000 Euro kalt,
plus Nebenkosten. Für 76 m2.
Man muss aber auch dazu sagen,
dass die möbliert vermietet wird.
Möbliert werden Wohnungen
immer etwas teurer vermietet.
Kannst du sagen, was du ungefähr
für so eine Wohnung bezahlst?
Ja, über eine halbe Mio.
Hast jetzt all dein Geld investiert?
Oder hast du wirklich auch so viel
auf dem Konto? - Sowohl, als auch.
(Zuruf:) Wie viel Geld hast du
konkret? Kannst du das sagen?
Das geht dich gar nichts an.
So, was machen wir jetzt hier?
Hier schauen wir, dass
für einen Anzug für mich bekommen.
Ich habe 15 Kilogramm abgenommen.
Ich habe die Anzüge zwar
"runterschneidern" lassen.
Aber man sieht einfach,
dass der mal größer war.
Und das ist nicht ideal.
Nach was suchst du so ungefähr?
So etwas in etwa finde
ich schon ganz gut.
Was nicht so ganz klassisch ist.
Ja, dunkelblau mag ich gerne.
Vielleicht suche ich
mir auch einen aus.
So, nicht schlecht.
Sieht spitze aus, sehr gut.
Mit Fliege, steht dir.
Deiner sitzt auch sehr gut.
400 Euro ist schon
ein angemessener Preis.
Nimmst du den jetzt direkt mit?
Ich nehme den mit, auf jeden Fall.
Ich finde den gut.
Wenn ich den so nehmen würde,
wie ich jetzt hier stehe,
dann würde der
ungefähr 1000 Euro kosten.
Krass. Das ist teuer.
Du könntest jedoch
easy so einen Anzug leisten.
Ich würde es dann machen,
wenn es was Besonderes sein soll.
Das ist schon ein Anzug,
den ich einmal oder zweimal
im Monat anziehe.
Ich finde, da reicht ein Anzug,
der 400 Euro kostet.
Da muss das
kein mega exklusiver sein.
Ich gucke mich die ganze Zeit
so im Spiegel an.
Wenn man so etwas Schickes anhat,
dann guckt man sich so gerne an.
Stimmt. Sieht auch sehr gut aus.
So könnte ich
eigentlich auch rumlaufen.
Ich könnte so als Millionär
durchgehen? - Ja, warum nicht.
Du könntest auch in deinem Hoodie
als Millionär durchgehen.
Wie man aussieht,
das hat nichts damit zu tun.
Ob man vermögend ist oder nicht.
Ich ärgere mich immer, wenn ich
mir Klischees eingestehen muss.
Aber das ist eins, was ich hatte.
Millionäre
laufen immer ganz schick rum.
Nein, nicht immer.
Manchmal.
Ist fast ein bisschen schade,
dass ich nicht Millionär bin.
Dann würde ich ihn
vielleicht mitnehmen. - Okay.
Ja, sag Bescheid.
Dann kann ich dir helfen.
Was würdet ihr mit 1 Mio. Euro
auf dem Konto machen?
Schreib mir
das mal in die Kommentare.
Und wenn ihr keine Folge
aus der Reihe
"Was macht Geld mit uns?"
verpassen wollt,
dann lasst mir ein Abo da.
Untertitel: ARDtext
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)